probably don't want but there is because
you're putting a limit but when it comes
to lgbqt and there's plus there's many
other things there's it's open but when
and also for example there are some men
who are coming out unseen why can't they
join your group and I'd appear at the
end
you make
about people
there's no statement why is the back of
this person's head blown out oh it's
their face but they say with we're born
like that yeah
you know I've kind of changed my mind on
this like I don't know if people are
really boring gay and my reasoning is
because I feel like the number of gay
people it rises every year and I feel
like you're talking about it to young
kids they're more likely to become gay
like if you're you know like they're
doing like they're shoving like pronouns
and stuff down to kids throats at a
younger age then they're more likely to
become that thing rather than it just
being born inside of them you know what
I mean like how like there's more
transgender logic but I don't agree okay
okay I could be wrong does that make
sense yeah okay and the reason is the
whole gender thing we're watching people
you know they're they're transitioning
and they're they're a few years later
going back and being like Oh my God
they're horrified and mortified and
sometimes traumatized because they took
a physical they made physical changes
that are irreversible so there's that
that doesn't happen necessarily with
being gay second of all as far as what
you're into like what you're what your
your natural urges are you can't be
talked into that I'm heterosexual
straight up I've never desired to be
with a woman or any kind of you know
non-binary creature but I can tell you
that there are plenty of men who I
wouldn't go near with a 10-foot pole
because I'm not attracted to them so I
don't even want to be up but close and
personal with the sex I'm attracted to
so to tell tell me that you can you know
then talk people into being gay and when
they're naturally not I don't buy it and
I say that from my own personal you know
like just that feeling that I just
explained but also I think part of the
reason that the numbers of gays may be
increasing is truly because of social
it's the water it's the fluoride truly
because of social Acceptance Now this
LGB this uh trans this transgender thing
the increase is because of brainwashing
of young children and it is so there's
this guy check him out on Twitter his
name is billboard Chris he is
anti-pushing transgenderism on children
he just wants it kept away from the kids
something happens when you grow up fine
but keep it away from the kids because
they're talking children who are in
puberty and just like I'm comfortable
yeah it's uncomfortable being a teenager
can be really awkward unless you're like
the super cool kids so they talk them
into transitioning because it's
something to glom onto and it's a club
to belong to when you feel uncomfortable
so that's why that's happening but
nobody's really becoming more gay
because of that you think you could be
talked into being gay no I know I
couldn't but maybe if I grew up in a
household with gay parents and
constantly talked about in school then
I'm assuming the stats would be more
likely that I'd be gay I don't think so
I think you might look at it differently
and consider it and go and question am I
but at the end of the day you either or
you aren't like you know you know who
you want to snuggle with and that's all
there is to it I understand your logic
but I I think it's flawed and missing
context
born like most people would think like
as in a straight like we're not just
talking about that kind of thing we're
talking about people who are uh being
discriminated for the gender they love
not necessarily the age the gender
if a murderer says they want to kill
someone else and they're just like that
you're not gonna let them kill someone
else you're gonna do everything you can
to stop them from hurting someone else
same with pedophiles if someone says oh
I was just born like that and they want
to hurt someone you need to stop them
from hurting someone lgbtq people aren't
hurting anyone in fact we're the ones
being hurt by other people you are
hurting people you are hurting children
now you never used to the LGB is never
used it's not yeah the lgbts I can't say
it enough the TQ pluses are losing it oh
yeah who cares if you're like gay or
lesbian like I don't know but what I'm
saying is this can be argued for example
hurting what does hurting mean and it
hurts someone physically or having a
harmonic society as a whole the Ripple
effects of that that's something that
needs to be discussed because if one
says argument's sake when I drink
alcohol I don't hurt anybody but you're
the same person when you're doing
alcohol you go crash into a car with
kids in there and you kill so like in
Islam as Muslims Islam is prevention but
even rather than cure so meaning if
alcohol if one person says I want my
right to drink alcohol Islam says no if
you're going to have a impact a negative
impact on the community you can't do
that because the community at large has
a greater right but what I was asking
you guys look I'm not trying to attack
you guys I'm curious yeah but when I see
inconsistency I have to you can do the
same with me when you draw a line with
the pedophiles when you draw a line with
incest I'm asking the question
for example the pedophile movement
actually bestiality even yeah they they
want to join your group they even like
you know there's some discussions where
they're like why can't and the LGBT
group are denying that they say no you
can't but they're saying we're born this
way why is it that when you're born a
gay homosexual bisexual a transsexual
what if it may transgender whatever
you're born you have a right but there's
consent there I want to hear his point
um like it to a child and
even act on it I have that accept me as
I am you did reject them
they're hurting people
what about incest a father and a
daughter that's reached the age of 16.
it's a good point though like where do
you draw the line because it's like they
keep pushing the line that's the thing
is that it's not like it's just here
it's like you can be lesbian and gay
it's like now the line's here now the
lines here now the lines here now girls
can play and I mean men can play in
women's sports it's like they just don't
stop but what they've done is they now
buy the tqia's blend of glomming onto
the lgbs is they've combined sexuality
with identity first of all the whole
identity conversation is just I gotten
to the point of being a goddamn circus
but do you understand just let me make
this point because combining you know
sexuality is different from Identity
yeah and that's where they are hurting
people so this girl's acting like you're
not hurting anybody but you are because
now you've brought it you've got it all
intertwined and you're bringing it into
children you are hurting kids just as
much as the pedophile because children
shouldn't be talking thinking living
that period I was gonna say how it was
funny how our generation used to be so
against the labels and stuff like that
like we're not labels were free yet they
go around with their Flags talking about
who they like to stick their Pisha doing
non-stop who cares why are you why are
you telling everybody that I don't see
straight people going around being like
I'm straight yeah it's just weird it's
nobody's business I don't care what goes
on in your bedroom I don't want to know
and the fact that we have no class
anymore no discretion oh ROM let's keep
going shouldn't be talking about your
husband or your wife or your partner in
the street contraceptive
as we said that father is in a position
of power over the daughter like do you
respect your father okay what what age
does the child need to reach so they're
not in a position of power because
because there is no age because yeah but
that could be with anyone that could be
without two gay couples and one is more
manipulative
so if a teacher has a position of power
over a child in a classroom and the
teacher starts convincing the child that
its gender is wrong and that it should
be considering what it's like to have a
butt plug up their ass when they're 12.
that teacher is wrong by this logic yet
she'll still defend teaching children
guaranteed
comes and says I'm 16 years old my
father is not manipulative and I choose
the right to have sexual intimacy with
him how could you come and say no he's
your father he must be manipulative
you're over generalizing how is that
fair on them and they love
we're not saying he's necessarily 100
manipulative we're saying that that
person is in a position of power over
the daughter correct do you like
acknowledge that that person they are
until that person reaches the age of
puberty 16 because they have they have a
lot of Rights you know they can call the
FED in two seconds okay
okay how is this relevant relevant
because what it is is what we're just
trying to do is like what I'm trying to
find out is because I feel like there's
inconsistency with the lgbtqt community
um and this is where um where I'm saying
well there's a contradiction that's what
I'm trying to highlight and I'm trying
to tell me if I'm wrong so that's why I
was trying to have a dialogue with you
guys because it seems a contradiction to
your very stance
why do you draw the straight line at men
and women being in relationships and not
at all people of any gender as being in
relationships okay
is what I'm asking okay with us we come
from an objective morality where we
believe God Almighty has created us and
we live in his land and he provides us
the sustenance and what he says we try
our best to follow
um now obviously as Muslims in this
country we abide by the law of the land
yeah
um so you guys can like I'm not here to
stop you do what you're doing but what
we're trying to say is for example from
our point of view it's for example we
believe that God Almighty has
um forbidden it it's not permissible
yeah and not only that for example there
there are many issues as well for
example it's unnatural I believe it's
unnatural even though you can say okay
it was Animal Kingdom but I can I can
say that's animals but what I'm saying
is unnatural for a man for example uh to
penetrate another man's uh rectum you
know and and that's from our point of
view but but I'm not I'm not I'm not
saying you guys don't have to I'm sorry
Freedom consent to being filmed
could you please take that down yeah
whoever's recording Mike in your face
three minutes later
I didn't consent to being real
dumbass okay
yeah
okay all right guys where is recording
this they don't want to be in here
whoever did this blurs did a hilarious
job
let me see what he's saying about it
yeah they don't want to be in here yeah
because I think the speaker's going up
you get 10 cameras can't control them
yeah so so oh so this is just someone
else's camera so
our position right I'm just going to sum
up in one
what do you think about dudes painting
their nails like rock stars and like
celebrities do it like I don't know I've
never been into that or had any urges to
paint my nails think about it I don't
think about it at all I don't have any
thoughts I don't care God
it's okay for any adult consensus who
does not have uh parental or like
familial relationship with someone else
it's okay for them to have a
relationship the LGBT
Society this guy though real quick who
has black fingernails has exceedingly
feminine hands I was gonna so I was
gonna say in that case I I don't think
you need to go any more feminine than
just your natural hands fella the whole
parents of the whole parents will think
of being manipulative
people lovely lady hands
might be a lady maybe he's a lady and
took some hormones to maybe have a
deeper voice because
the whole manipulative thing because
that's the first time I've heard that
wow but it's partially because of that
it's also partially because genetic it's
for a lot of different reasons and I
obviously haven't I haven't prepared for
this we're just here for that we haven't
prepared this I couldn't tell you every
argument but we don't endorse incest and
all we're saying is that anyone who's
over a legal age of consent should be
allowed to have a relationship with
anyone else and that's fine you're a
really nice guy thank you thank you very
much I'm so sorry again and I agree I
agree with that final statement that he
made and actually these people were not
so bad no they were really respectful
and somewhat reasonable even a nice
goodbye like that Ali dawa I think is a
nice respectful guy yeah I don't think
he was being too like outrageous there
or going after them yeah I think that
was a mutually respectful conversation
and I actually agree with the last thing
that this kid said if somebody is the
age of consent they should be able to
have a relationship with who they choose
that's that's just what I believe and in
the eyes of God I might not be wrong but
in the eyes of the government
I'm saying like the eyes of the
government like I just think the
government shouldn't be intervened in
that stuff at all even if you're Pro or
against gay marriage or whatever gay
people it's like still I don't think
it's any of our business like it's not
like abortions were at least like that's
more serious and you can have a more
firm opinion but that's a matter of life
and death so I think it's more serious
than just you know if two gay guys want
to live together and do what they want
in their bedroom it's like stop that
just keep it there I don't want you want
to hear about it at the end of the day
I'm sorry I don't mind hearing about it
like I'm okay with I mean like the stuff
like like that I don't want to hear
about the intimate the details of my
hetero couple friends did you watch Bill
Burr yeah
he's like oh he's saying how he was at a
Denny's and he looked over and there
were these two guys kissing and
instinctually he was like ooh and his
girlfriend was like what are you
homophobic and he's like no but when I
was 12 and I watched a video for the
first time I was like I want to do that
that's what I want to do just by Nature
it's just like your reaction he's like
that doesn't just it doesn't look right
I'll tell you when if I'm at Denny's and
the guy at the next booth and a girl and
I can see him he's on the other side of
the next Booth if I see him and he takes
a bite out of a big mayonnaise sandwich
and I catch his mouth open for a second
full of mayonnaise I go okay does that
mean I hate that man no no exactly it
just means that there's something that
he's doing that is unnatural to me like
eating mayonnaise because it's
disgusting why are you hating on
mayonnaise you [ __ ] have a mayonnaise
Pro mayonnaise parade in front of the
house tomorrow it's not going to change
make the mayonnaise
[Laughter]
discussion all right thank you guys so
much for watching make sure to like
subscribe follow me on Instagram at
sunnyfast I'm giving a hundred dollars
to someone who follows me follow me on
Instagram I'm not giving away anything
because you know Kenny says
[Music]
[Music]